Timothy young lives in Deming New Mexico
with his wife and three children
in October 2012 young was pulled over by
deputy Xavier Peru in Lordsburg a town
about an hour west of Deming I was at
the phalange stopped to get gas I had a
friend of mine along accident the
vehicle
his deputy Peru he stated that I need to
get back in the vehicle
ask him what what it was for what was
going on and he stated for not using my
turn signal
I give him a consent to search the truck
they searched it for two to a half hours
approximately he didn't tell you in the
settlement no he said that he said as
far as he know that there is nothing in
they said on it I said well you know as
far the dagger phallus that maybe you
guys are transporting drugs down here
maybe the tires are serving so I know we
gotta wait for the dog to get her tooth
but yeah just keep just keep looking
tell about this is the part that
I feel there's something in here but
we're just we don't we put my business
for pushing beetle that was not going to
get on your vehicle
Oh what's also more Jessica's is the
forming a dog that really wants to
transit oh yeah a real pretty good dogs
with our department it has there been
any drugs inside that vehicle and
there's no drugs in there now - who's
our winner we're an American icon Sam
because check him real good no not yet
anything on the driver's seat inside the
vehicle and then also on the center
console inside the do it I agreed to the
dropping of the pants with what's the
boxers up they he wanted more than that
he says he made it sound like I was
gonna go home he was gonna release me
you know if I would just pull down my
boxers as well I did didn't want to but
I did do you have any cocaine no do you
have any heroin
[Music]
here's here's here's what's gonna happen
okay
we're gonna do a search warrant on your
truck and we're gonna do a search
warrant on you because here's what I
believe use me if you do a search one on
me yeah here's what I believe that's
where I have a problem fine I need to do
its marshal or somebody here the witness
just don't trust the Sheriff Department
are you having up your ass what a
[ __ ] question that's it it's an
honest question what up my ass you have
drugs in your eye get me to what you
have drugs in your ass do you know some
of your ass if there's not yet done to
worry about but I'm pretty confident
through it okay but let's bend over and
check either - all right yeah it'll work
for that the district judge did approve
this warrant okay so this is what's
gonna happen is we're going to take you
to the hospital
and we're gonna do the x-rays and
they're gonna strip-search okay
all right roll well we got there fun
costly 45 minutes an hour later they
actually my stomach actually my pelvic
area and they didn't find nothing it was
negative
okay that being said they still took me
back to the to the ER the officers
present they said they were gonna do a
anal finger exam as soon as he
penetrated they left after not finding
nothing in the stool but stool then they
still kept me handcuffed wrote
handcuffed all the way that hour drive
back down to the Lord Spartan where they
took me back to my job and had no choice
but to release
it's probably three or four weeks after
after in fact and I go no box and open
the my box and there's a bill from Gila
River Medical Center for that night that
we're speaking on and I left I mean
that's all I could do was laugh I'm one
of the crowd but I just left